bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france comment d'abord
réagissent les libanais au retour de
saad hariri le premier ministre qui
avait démissionné l'année dernière sous
la pression de la rue alors commençons
d'abord un lob sur la maison sociaux
plus de groupe de la contestation
populaire qui a éclaté on en appelle le
17 octobre 2019 dont plusieurs groupes
de la contestation populaire dénoncent
cette nomination il estime que alors que
sa qualité assurent une part de
responsabilité dans la corruption et
dans l'effondrement un peu du système
économique et financier que le dont le
pays est le théâtre
actuellement donc il leur vie souligne
qu'il est irrationnel de favoriser le
retour au pouvoir de quelqu'un qui
assume une part qu donc de
responsabilité dans la crise et
l'effondrement actuel
à ce niveau de la contestation là haut
niveau des milieux politiques met à mal
les avis sont plus nuancés
de nombreux mineurs politique et même
certains vidéo populaire estime que le
liban ne peut plus se permettre
il est invité à une situation de
défendre e mendel qui n'est plus ce
qu'elle peut plus se permettre le luxe
d'attendre encore des bouleversements et
que la contestation arrive à son terme
et que la contestation mûrissent pour
pour déboucher sur une refonte disons de
pouvoir politique donc ce milieu là
disent que le temps presse
et ça effectivement c'est vrai la
situation socio économique au liban est
devenue intenable pour entrer dans les
pharmacies il n'a pas de médicaments
les banques sont à faire face aux
demandes des clients et même l'egypte le
liban les moyens ne n'arrive plus
vraiment a ajouté sa vie quotidienne
donc effective par des citations sur son
économie ne peut plus mener mais elle
est invitée à ce que défense existe
ailleurs le quai d'orsay vial de il ya
deux jours bien
avant-hier bien publié un communiqué
disant que le liban
ne peut plus se permettre le luxe
d'attendre qu'il faut faire vite qu'il
faudra former un gouvernement rapidement
pour faire face à la crise économique et
sociale dans le cadre des initiatives
françaises est avocat de la feuille de
route qui prévoit leur la feuille de
route française qui a écrit abriel
proposé par le fils d'amadou gon le 1er
septembre dernier
alors justement c'est justement la
france la france quel rôle joue-t-elle
dans les décisions politiques libanaises
alors elle joue redisons rôles de deux
catalyseurs de facilitateur si on peut
me permettez l'expression à ce que la
classe politique libanaise se débattait
un peu dans ses contradictions et dans
cet événement il fallait peut-être
quelque part qu'il y ait un catalyseur
comme comme en chimie un catalyseur et
hergé qui qui qui favorise rapidement un
déblocage et l amorce d'une solution
donc leur phrasé se situer à ce niveau
le président m'a proposé une feuille de
route le 1er septembre dernier qui a été
agréé par toutes les factions politiques
libanaises toutes communautés confondues
seulement le problème c'est que le
premier ministre qui avait été chargé de
former un gouvernement non partisan
il a été confronté en fait à des
demandes de ceux qu'on appelle ici le
duo chiite formé du raisonnable du
mouvement à main qui ai insisté pour lui
même d'abord une aux mains du ministre
des finances
et pour nommer des mini si ceux qui
aiment qui mettait en cause toute la
logique de l'initiative française qui
vise à former justement un gouvernement
qui ne soit pas partisan qu'il a un
gouvernement qui soit indépendant de la
classe politique actuelle
alors c'est le défi qu'a repris
aujourd'hui avec la différence comme sa
vie mais avec assise populaire
évidemment beaucoup plus large que le
premier ministre désigné et qui c'est
qui a abandonné la partie les appels que
semaine et il a surtout une audience
internationale
beaucoup plus importante
le premier ministre qui l'ont précédé et
semble-t-il peu difficile
merci à vous michel thomas aimerait bien
décrit ce constat un sévère pour le
liban qui fait face donc c'est une crise
économique sociale politique et a aussi
cette terrible explosion s'en souvient
l'été dernier et puis le coup vite 19
également merci à vous je rappelle qu'on
est rédacteur en chef du quotidien
l'orient le jour